gran parte de la conferencia de los
océanos se celebra fuera del recinto
donde las delegaciones dan sus discursos
y hoy se llevó a cabo una carrera contra
la extinción de los arrecifes de coral
donde organizaciones públicas y privadas
se reunieron para poner el foco en estos
ecosistemas que tanto sufren los
impactos del cambio climático y del
calentamiento global una carrera contra
el tiempo a bordo de un velero con
mensajes en sus velas sobre el aumento
de las temperaturas y la desaparición de
los arrecifes de coral unos lienzos
hechos de materiales reciclados
representantes de kenia país con citroen
junto con portugal de la conferencia de
los océanos hablaron de cómo estos
eventos crean conciencia mientras que el
programa de desarrollo de las naciones
unidas recalcó como sus programas
podrían ayudar a estos ecosistemas
youznhy los arrecifes de coral son el
corazón de la economía del océano o
economía sur y la economía azul es el
corazón de la salud del planeta y del
crecimiento y bienestar del planeta que
a su vez es la clave de nuestra salud y
bienestar ahora ocho meses prédica de
nuestra promesa por el océano se basa en
nuestra visión de la economía azul
incluye no sólo restaurar con ayuda de
nuestros aliados el billón de dólares en
pérdidas socioeconómicas que el mal
manejo del océano ha causado sino
también crear un sustento y vida es
decir océanos limpios lejos en life
clean air rose jones unas ayudas que los
corales necesitan desesperadamente
puesto que la mitad de estos ecosistemas
han desaparecido en los últimos 50 años
y se estima que sin acciones urgentes el
resto podría extinguirse en las próximas
tres décadas